pierre bonjour on le disait la
manifestation est partie en début
d'après midi quelle est l'atmosphère
autour de vous eh bien écoutez olivier
plusieurs milliers de personnes se sont
réunis cet après-midi pour cette
manifestation vous l'avait dit pour la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papiers des manifestants qui manifestent
aussi pour d'autres causes notamment la
fermeture des centres de rétention
administrative ou encore pour le
logement pour tous vous lisiez ils sont
des milliers à être parti depuis tout à
l'heure
du côté de la place de la nation un
cortège qui s'arrêtent très souvent très
régulièrement arrêtés à parra les forces
de police qui sont en tête de ce cortège
mais qui file tout doucement vers sa fin
du côté de à stalingrad
on a rencontré à des personnes des
travailleurs qui souhaitent être
régularisés tout à l'heure où au sein de
cette manifestation je vous propose d'en
écouter certains
on en a marre travail sans papiers c'est
une c'est difficile travail sans papiers
qui pourtant avait besoin d'aidé mais si
tu ne dis pas tu cites a pas de des
papiers et une copa travail
nous on n'a pas de salle et on vit dans
des conditions difficiles
péniblement c'est très difficile parce
que en france pour finalement en europe
quand apparaît pas bien mais c'est pas
facile mais pas contre tout ce qui nous
est dit comme les consignes nous avons
suivi donc ce que l'on veut mon dieu que
nous déclare histoire sent pas bien
parce que c'est pas facile quand je suis
tel toi tu peux pas travailler on est là
aujourd'hui pour réclamer un les
régularisation de tous les sans papiers
qui sont en territoire défense bayal est
certain qu'ils sont là ils ont travaillé
qu'on a les compliments même si l'avant
le continent il ya les ans qui
travaillent
c'est qu'on est plein de monde qui
travaille travaux noir aussi aussi le
sucre a fait là y'a plein de choses nous
juste on est bien ici et pour demander
pour montrer le président ou avec les
populations pour qu'elles puissent nous
aider pour que le gouvernement penner et
clarey tout le monde et puis parmi les
personnes que nous avons rencontrées
aujourd'hui des travailleurs issus de
tous les corps de métier a vraiment de
la restauration des personnes qui
travaillent dans les hôpitaux mais aussi
de nombreux elle livreur nous avons
rencontré dans ce cortège d'anciens
leaders de la marque fléchi
une marque qui livre des repas
à domicile une marque qui a changé sa
façon de recruter i qui ne compte plus
aujourd'hui les travailleurs sans
papiers nous avons rencontré tout à
l'heure jérôme pineau responsable du
collectif des livres autonome de bari je
vous propose de l'écouter à ce sujet le
problème c'est que comme on les
considère comme des travailleurs
indépendants des auto entrepreneurs
eh ben c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
vers 4 les régulariser que s'il était
salarié et donc leur propose c'est de
dire on n'est pas des vrais indépendant
on devrait être salarié pour simplifier
la procédure on est on est en contact
avec frichti alors frichti ils disent
qu'ils savaient pas sauf que des
messageries internes dont d'ailleurs
qu'on découvert le journal libération
montré qu'il savait très bien donc
maintenant leur but c'est d'essayer de
dire on savait pas on va les aider mais
pour les aider vraiment techniquement il
faut quand même qu'on leur montre qu'on
n'est pas qu'on est mobilisé pour voilà
pour que les choses aillent le plus vite
possible
voilà je vous disais donc plusieurs
mallié milliers de manifestants réunis
ici pour cette manifestation pour la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papiers une manifestation dans le calme
en musique dans une très bonne ambiance
et qui se dirige tout droit vers sa fin
à la place stalingrad dans le 19e
arrondissement de la capitale
merci pierre pour ces précisions pierre